uh i wouldn't say i was the 10 year old
that built the powerpoints but
i think that passion for communications
for being helpful for figuring out why
people buy
was something that was in my dna that
kind of drove through
finding that niche later in my career
for life welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
chief marketing officer what is that
about meet tara robertson the chief
marketing officer of teamwork
tara joined teamwork in february of 2021
as chief marketing officer and has over
20 years of global experience leading
award-winning marketing and sales teams
with a passion for growth and results
driven marketing terra is experienced in
managing full funnel marketing
strategies that drive both customer
acquisition
and retention before teamwork tara was
the head of customer marketing at sprout
social
and helped bring the company public in
tara robertson welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm good how are you thank you for
having me it is wonderful having you
here i know how
busy you are with transitioning to this
this new incredible opportunity as chief
marketing officer of teamwork
and you've taken on leadership marketing
roles as some of the most fascinating
companies like sprout social
hajjar i've used these platforms myself
and
and and so you did a good job as a
marketing i guess but for now what i'd
love to focus on
is is you know your own leadership
journey and what does it mean to be a
marketing leader
and what is a marketing leader you know
i'm a technology guy i'm an engineer i'm
not really
i don't know marketing very much so i'm
excited to hear
what it really comes down to and what is
it like leading marketers and and
thinking about growth in that capacity
and some of the insights you've learned
from this industry and all together so
tara
get me started do you always know from
when you're
little that that your passion is
marketing and growth is that is that an
obvious thing to you
yeah great question no i was not that
person and i'm jealous of those people
sometimes when they talk about their
story and they were
kids who built powerpoint presentations
to sell their parents on a dog
that they wanted i never actually did
any of that i think for me
what was always a passion is being
helpful
finding ways to work with people that
can help them grow in their career
finding ways to to figure out
what makes people want to buy the
psychology behind all of that like
that's what was most fascinating to me
and i think when i was in college and
still kind of in that journey of trying
to figure out what do i want to be
when i grow up uh the first time i took
a marketing class
was actually when that light bulb went
off and realized oh this is really
fascinating my undergrad degree was
actually in
communications when i was starting to
think through how to find
everything that we're thinking feeling
doing and all of those things that
didn't necessarily have
a job to it just yet and marketing
digital marketing
you know and this will age me was still
relatively new in a lot of the
the industry as a whole and i was i
loved it so much that that brought me
to immediately go and get my masters in
marketing
specifically in integrated marketing
communications
and launched me into my career so i
wouldn't say i was the
10 year old that built the powerpoints
but i think that passion for
communications for being helpful for
figuring out why people buy
was something that was in my dna that
kind of drove through
finding that niche later in my career
for life
and and you're not only you know in
marketing in leadership positions for
for you know marketing for for
traditional high-tech companies you're
marketing you're leading marketing in
companies that are helping other
marketing leaders
operate right that's it yeah it's a
pretty cool
idea that you're you're helping you know
market the tools that are going to help
other marketers
so tell me about this mindset of the
marketer well what who
who is a marketer and and what types of
things are
do you realize are important for them as
you go about navigating this
this really cool persona yeah it's
really all about
understanding who is the person that's
buying so
when i look at my own leadership style
and style of how i like to build
marketing campaigns and teams and
initiatives and really it's about taking
me out of the equation and thinking
about who's on the other side
and what is their experience that
they're going through i'm a big believer
and i will say this often marketing
should be about creating value
not about creating demand and so yes
demand is important if you don't have
demand you are not doing a good job
so you absolutely need to create it but
if you are not creating value first then
your demand isn't going to be as
successful
and so i think that's kind of at the
epicenter of the way that i think about
you know who's buying and to remember
that it's yes there's a b2b and a b2c
world but it's it's really neither of
those it's a human
to human approach and there's always
someone buying on the other end
so it's about understanding what is the
pain that they're having and then
build valuable solutions or valuable
content or valuable experiences
for them that's going to help them you
know grow and
and get that better version of what
they're looking for with your
product your service your solution etc
right and so when you're in a leadership
position i understand that this is all
critically important you know regardless
of of whatever of what
you know you employ this is the
foundation of it and then
as a leader i'm guessing that you have a
lot of different tools at your disposal
you have a lot of different types of
products that you could be marketing at
different times with different verticals
how do you how do you determine then the
priority how do you determine
what is the strategy that this company
needs to employ
to get from to to get from point a to
point b and and
explain to these personas that we can
actually provide a lot of value for them
how do you go about even thinking
strategically to navigate that oh that's
a great question
this could be a very big answer so i'm
going to try to
pull that in a little bit in terms of
how you would do that
first and foremost it starts with the
data and the data should
always align to what i would say is
quantitative and qualitative
right you've got your quantitative
insights in what are people doing how
are they interacting whether your
channel is your website
um whether it's something else what are
the things that are driving the most
impact when it comes to what people are
doing and then there's the qualitative
which is the part that often people will
not spend enough time in which is just
talking to your customers talking to
your prospects
understanding surveying and knowing the
why so you've got your what
you also need to know your why and then
when those things are partnering
together
you can actually start to draw patterns
and draw conclusions into
where you're seeing the biggest drop-off
points so you can lean in and focus on
those things specifically
i think in marketing um one everybody
thinks that they're a great marketer
so that that's certainly an area where
you need to make sure that you're
bringing education along for the ride
but two it is very easy to just throw a
bunch of spaghetti at the wall
and hope that it sticks because of the
amount of tactics out there and so if
you don't have
good insights and great data and a great
pattern for spending time with your
customers or your users
you probably aren't going to be
prioritizing the most important things
so start there and then ruthlessly
build out your roadmap and then even
more ruthlessly
say no to the spaghetti that way you can
make sure that you stay on track with
what your biggest patterns are and your
biggest opportunities
right well were there any times in your
career that you're sitting there and
you're saying like
i have no idea you know how to even
approach this
i'm not even sure you know who is this
persona you know what they like
is it does that exist in in the
marketing you know
flow where sometimes you're sitting
there and saying like wow i'm not really
even sure how to begin
thinking about this persona or marketing
this product
absolutely and i would say that that
happens all
the time right like that's that's the
big challenge that you have when it's
coming down to thinking about how do you
prioritize and make sure that you're
doing the right things
um or if there's too many things coming
in and you don't really know which one
comes first having to take a step back
and you know find whatever energy or
space
is the right space for you to just
brainstorm and have that time where you
think
i've often told my teams and this is
probably as a result of me being in that
just
manic state in my previous like earlier
stages in my career of just trying to go
and just trying to keep up is you need
to have a certain amount of time that
you're just sitting and like
honestly staring at a wall and thinking
and allowing yourself the space to think
am i poking holes in the right things am
i putting this together the right way
and the things that i don't know who can
i connect with or what books can i read
that can help me
understand some of these components that
i'm still trying to figure out because
that would
i would say obviously you know as you
grow in your career you become a lot
more confident
in being able to know what that road map
is when you're early on in your career
or an entrepreneur for example there are
so many things that you have to think
through
and so i think when you get that time to
think you can start to map those things
out and then figure out
you know how do you fill in the gaps
because you don't know what you don't
know
and it's a very dangerous place to to
try to answer those questions on your
own
no i'm sure and then i'm guessing that
you know part of the dissonance
in in the whole process that on one hand
marketing to me sounds like something
very very creative you're you're
innovating you know these both messaging
but graphics and and perceptions and
you're figuring out okay
how if i drive like this then this is
that how the psychology of the person is
gonna
you know think about this at the same
time you're saying okay but we're also
data driven
and we want to let points speak for
themselves and guide us as how to um how
to improve
so how do you then work you know when
you have this you know
when they're going against each other
sometimes the data says one thing
intuition says something else how does
that work then that is a
hard hard thing to to answer
uh i think every day right because uh on
every end
marketing can be either like right very
scientific
very data focused and on the other end
it can be very creative
the marriage of the two together is not
easy
and it's something that i don't think
you know anybody's really
truly mastered that on their own it's
where you actually can figure out
teams and you can figure out balance and
strength
and the way to make sure that people are
challenging each other where you can
marry the
creativity with the data and insights to
get to that true
beautiful magical initiative that you
want to run because if you over engineer
too much on the creative side and too
much on the gut side
then you end up with a brand campaign
that might not actually
drive the right results or drive the
right impact if you over engineer on
the data side and you're too rigid in
not being able to
test and try and make big bets then
you're also
in that risk-averse stage so it's really
finding the marriage and the way that
i've always
essentially executed against that is i
will start
on the data side like start in the area
where you know you've got numbers that
you need to hit
and there's just a general this is what
i need to do in order for my team to be
successful
and as you prove that out and you can do
it relatively quickly
that's when you can start to get a
little bit bigger with those big bets or
with those gut intuitions or more of
that creativity
where you've got the flexibility the
budget and the opportunity to think like
if this were to fail what would be the
impact of that because you want to fail
but you want to fail forward and not put
all your eggs too much in that gut
basket
right that makes a lot of sense and one
of one of the things that i've always
been very curious about is
traditionally i've met the most of the
founders
that i've met were not from they weren't
wearing the marketing hat
or they weren't passionate about
marketing themselves sometimes they are
their engineers
sometimes they're you know their product
people and so then you add to the
leadership
team you know a chief marketing officer
that is responsible really for the
growth
you know in many capacities right and at
the end
it sort of the company then shifts from
okay we have product we found product
market fit
and now sort of the responsibility is
shifting more to the marketing and
growth side to
to now get this out there and to make
sure that people use it
so how does the relationship and balance
with the leadership work
when on one hand you might have you know
some leadership that
aren't really working with marketing or
don't even understand marketing
but then you have the marketing that is
really sort of guiding
the industry or guiding where the
company is headed how does that work
yeah i think there's two things that are
important there the first one and you
hear a lot of marketing leaders talk
about this where
they'll say hey if your founder your ceo
doesn't believe in marketing
it's not worth it um and i to a degree
that could be right but i think it's
also our job to make sure you bring
people along for the journey
and you properly communicate your plan
your strategy
and your roadmap and and what you're
trying to do because there are often
it's really dependent on the kind of
founder that you're working with and the
leadership team that you're
set up with on are they heavily product
focused or heavily engineering focused
are they sales and marketing focused and
regardless
they're still opinions and i think part
of what is really important is from the
beginning
you set those expectations on this is
what i plan to do this is where i want
to
address this is this the right fit for
how we'll work together because that
working style
is critically important and then the
second part is just
over communicate especially in those
early days i'm in my early days right
now at teamwork and so
you know i'm sending weekly emails out
and updates on here's what i'm working
on or
30 60 90 day plans and then structuring
it between when we're looking at
people process data systems all the
things so that you have that opportunity
to allow
people to poke holes in it and people to
ask questions as they're learning
um and i'd imagine that if you're if
you're joining any of these stages
either as a marketer or looking for your
first marketer
before they join the team you have those
conversations on
can we work together is this something
that we're investing in can we build the
right trust because everything starts
with trust
and then from there it's really looking
at making sure that you've got that open
line of communication
and opportunity to just make sure that
you can build on the trust that's been
established
right and i'm assuming that a lot of
them the you know
marketing that is out that goes outside
of the company
i'm guessing that a lot of the time it
reflects also on the culture
internally with the company and how
internally the company markets the
products
to themselves so when you join in now as
a chief marketing officer
as teamwork or vp marketing in other
areas
and you find maybe that messaging needs
to change or
the perceptions behind products need to
change
how do you even go about you know
thinking that okay i'm coming into this
big organization
i have this intuition that maybe there
are different things we should think
about differently
how do you even go about trying to align
you know moving the needle within
an organization that has has a culture
has roots
has perception about its pr about its
products
yeah i think that really depends on the
stage that you're entering into
and the propensity of you know what is
the story of the brand
i've been really lucky to work for some
incredible brands
uh and incredible founders that have
always kind of just been very supportive
of the way that we execute and go to
market but at the same time within each
one of them there was a very unique
nuance to what made that brand special
there was a very unique nuance to how we
acquired customers how we got them into
the funnel how we looked at
attaining revenue and so one is
you know i think it's really important
that you enter into these experiences
and these businesses
you know with your experience but also
with an open mindset that you have to
understand the uniqueness of this
business and of this brand
because the worst thing to do is to come
in and say oh i'm going to come in and
build brand new
positioning or overhaul our website and
create a brand new brand
because i want to put my stake in the
ground like that's not your job
as a cmo your job is to elevate the
brand to
build it to a level that really starts
to build out that
personality and that perception
especially when you're joining something
that's
more growth stage and less startup um
i'm entering into the culture at
teamwork
as much as you know i'm bringing the
culture that i'll hopefully bring to our
marketing team and so
i don't want to change that i want to
elevate it that's part of what i'm
excited
about working on with that team but also
elevate it to a way where we can
showcase
um our brand and you mentioned this and
i love that you mentioned it our
employer brand
because there is the component of brand
positioning
awareness and perception and all of that
for our ideal customers
there's also a huge component of this is
who we are
and makes us unique and that's that's
part of what people care about right now
and in a digital world so i think that
it's it's not necessarily coming
in and trying to change anything it's
recognizing that you have a perception
but you also have to build off of their
way of doing things and find that that
right connection
right so this question may seem obvious
but i'm i'm i am curious you know is i
understand that the marketing
has completely transformed from left
even 20 years ago to today i'm i'm
you know the number of verticals and the
ways to market
i've grown you know by a few factors if
not exponentially
the the persona the types of people that
you're selling to is different
generation gaps are widening
and you're depending on your demographic
you're choosing different messaging
do you expect marketing to continue
changing at the same rate
moving forward in 10 years are we going
to see
a whole different way of marketing than
we do than we see today
absolutely um that's you know i think
especially when you say 10 years there's
no way for us to know what's going to
happen in the next 10 years
you know i mentioned earlier when i was
getting my master's degree in
integrative marketing
there was no digital marketing or
inbound marketing that wasn't like 20
years ago
so it's crazy when you think about how
much has changed
and even if you think about how much has
changed this past year with the world
just doing what happened to the world uh
the way that we buy
the way that we consume the way that we
interact and the way we enter into
funnels is completely changed and
evolved and so
we're going to take those experiences
with us businesses are changing
and marketing absolutely needs to evolve
and that's part of what
i've always been just constantly reading
learning networking
and challenging my teams to do the same
because if you continue to just think
this is the way of doing things then
you're already behind
so i think just staying on top of it and
continuing to learn and to see what's
happening and
and you know look at social clubhouse
that's that's brand new and came out of
nowhere
and so you can see a ton of adopters
tick tock also relatively new within the
last couple years so
you know there are just all these
emerging channels and opportunities to
connect
and grab on to the digital ecosystem and
landscape that
you know it's just critical as marketers
specifically we're on the front lines we
need to
you know absolutely stay on top of that
amazing tara i have a few uh fun
questions are you ready
yeah i'm ready all right number one
at your favorite subject in school what
is it
12. it's a great question and i had two
answers to start and it's funny that i
wrote these down
um because they aligned to our
conversation is i just really loved art
and science like
i absolutely loved in art just getting
messy
and creating and building things but
then i also really love mixing chemicals
together in science and seeing the
reaction
to them so i think just hands on um
those were
by far my favorite subject amazing all
right
one of your role models fictional or
real
oh so i this cheesy answer my husband is
my role model
we definitely over the last decade
transitioned our home life balance he's
a stay-at-home dad
and stays with our kids and honestly no
matter how hard
i work and no matter what i've got on my
plate his job is just so much harder
and i just you know i really appreciate
him and look up to what he's been able
to bring on in a non-traditional way for
our family
that's beautiful and the hardest
question uh three words that you would
choose to describe yourself for
if i were to ask your husband how would
he describe you oh
it'd probably be different um
i'll try my best um i would say the ways
i would want to be described and
hopefully these are the ways i would one
is positive
i'm a glass huffle person no question
really like to look at every
challenge as an opportunity um lively
so i have a lot of energy and generally
that's something that'll bring to
most conversations and helpful i think
just you know if
there's something that i leave alone or
leave behind
me in kind of my life it's just being
able to be helpful
i love it alright thank you so so much
this is wonderful and i
know how busy you are thank you for
being so generous with your time
and stay safe and still healthy thank
you for coming on
yeah thank you this is wonderful i
really and great questions that was fun
take care